Saludos Valentina estoy a una decena de
metros del camión que transporta la
madre de nael El joven asesinado ayer
por un agente de la policía en esta
marcha que inició en la ciudadela de
Pablo Picasso de donde es originaria la
familia materna del joven y que va a
terminar en la prefectura de aquí de
nanter donde ocurrió el incidente la
marcha transcurre hasta el momento
pacíficamente sin embargo acerca de
cuatrocientos metros de aquí hemos visto
desfilar Ya varias decenas de camiones
de la policía con lo cual con lo cual
suponemos que en algún momento se teme
que la marcha pueda degenerarse nos
aseguró por parte de oficiales de la
prefectura que se evitaría ese escenario
un escenario confrontacional en
cualquier momento puedo decirte que esta
marcha del Silencio pudiera catalogarse
más bien como la marcha de las voces las
voces de cientos de residentes
delanteras que han salido a expresar
este apoyo a la familia de joven y
rechazo a los abusos de poder cometidos
por la muchas personas vestidas con
camisetas blancas como lo pidió la mamá
del joven consignas y pancartas donde se
lee justicia paranael policías asesinos
la policía mata acá esas siglas en
inglés que significa todos los policías
son bastardos hasta aquí han llegado
también caminan junto al camión que
transporta a la madre de nael varios
políticos entre ellos el alcalde de
nanter y diputados a la asamblea
nacional
ante hay mucha atención Eso sí puedo
decirte sabemos que el gobierno está
desplegando en varias ciudades
digamos diputados elegidos del gobierno
para tratar de cambiar de calmar la
situación que algunos de ellos incluso
han logrado concesiones eh por parte de
las personas para que no ejecuten
acciones violentas pero nada de eso
parece suficiente no sé si escuchas en
este momento
la algarabía los gritos de las personas
en apoyo a esa madre que en este momento
está en el vehículo tocando su corazón
en forma en signo de agradecimiento a
las personas que la acompañan en este
momento están dolorosos resumen hace una
marcha pacífica por el momento en un
contexto tenso que mantiene conmovida a
gran parte de los franceses